Welcome to the coding portions of lesson three. In this
lesson, we're going to learn how to use Objectify to
save entities in the datastore. We're going to use entities of
kind profile to save user profile information. And we're going to
learn how to get the user ID of a logged
in user to use it to generate a unique ID
for the entity's key. Once we've created some data and
saved it in the datastore, we're going to use the Datastore Viewer
in the Admin Console to look at the data that we've saved. Make sure that
it saved like we thought it would. And
there's no point putting data into the datastore
if you can't get it back out. So then we're going to learn how to get
an entity out of the datastore if you
know its key. Let's go create some profiles.